98% of the world's people are spending
98% of their time on things that don't matter you have free choice always
About everything but for goodness sakes stop making free choices and call yourself the victim of them
Wake up life. Will never make sense to your mind if you're trying to get life to make sense with your mind
You might as well forget it
Need motivation watch a top 10 with believe nation
what's up at 7 my 1 word is believe and I believe in you I believe you have an
Amazing gift inside you that I want to see
exploded under the world
so let's get your motivation to
Attend and get you believing in you grab a snack and chew in today's lessons from a man who went from being in a car
Accident and breaking his neck to being homeless and having to live in a tent making money by getting recycled cans and selling them to
Surviving homelessness eventually writing the best-selling book conversations with God and 29 books he's Neale Donald Walsch
And here's my take on his top 10 rules to success enjoy
Alright let's kick things off with rule number one shift your values up for the first 50 years of my life ition
I thought that my life was about me I
Had the attitude of a 10 year old or a 9 year old or a 6 year old?
But I had that attitude when I was 29 or 39. I just you know. I thought that wasn't a bad person
I'm not try to paint myself is this horrible individual, but I was fairly self-centered
I was looking at my own career my own goals my old objectives my own needs my own wants my own desires I
Tried to be even-handed about it if somebody helped me how I tried to give back if I could and all those things that were
taught to do but
Basically my life was focused on me
Fascinatingly even though my life was focused on me virtually all the time
My life wasn't working. I mean at some point in my life. I really got oh gosh
I can't seem to find happiness that lasts more than a little while like I can't seem to
Find success
That lasts was it a little while - everything is so ephemeral it just comes in and goes out comes in and goes out
I never seem to get anywhere to the top of the mountain when when is to struggle over this?
What I was experiencing when I had my first
Conversation with God so that's the context that's the background why I was given that wisdom because I asked God okay?
Obviously there's something here. I don't understand I
I've listened to what my daddy told me and listen to what my mommy told me I listen to what my
Religion told me I listen to what my culture told me, but there's some missing data. I felt that there was just some information
That was missing so I said to God. What is it?
What is it that I don't understand here the understanding of which would change everything God said to me Neil. It's really very simple
That she said what you just said here Neil your life is not about you
Your life is about everyone else whose life. You touch and the way in which you touch it
and I said
I don't understand they were supposed to give up everything that I ever wanted her
Desired her hoped for give up all of my goals all of my objectives, and she said no
No, no
I didn't say that I didn't say that
You don't have to set aside all of your goals
Set aside all of your objectives set aside all of the things to follow your desires
No
I didn't say that
But it's about achieving them working toward them moving toward them in a whole different way for a whole different reason
If you're doing those things to enrich the lives of everyone whose life you touch watch the world
fall in on you
with Wonder and joy and celebration
But if you're doing those things together to gather gather gather and get can't can't have more have more have more that you just like
You know you just want to get as much as you can for yourself if that's your prime motivation
You're going to be struggling every day for the rest of your life rule number two connect with your soul
But if we ever began to live our daily life from moment to moment
Moving in side the wisdom of our soul. I just finished a book
Which will be out in a few months called?
the only thing that matters
and the only thing that matters argues for the
Combining of the mind and the soul in the consideration of our daily choices and decisions
See the mind holds nothing, but experience which it imagines to be knowledge knowledge that experience is not knowledge
It's simply experience and your experience can be warped by all manner of things
Knowledge true knowledge is held in the soul
Eternal wisdom is held in the soul so our job as human beings is to find a way to marry
The minds experience with the souls knowledge and to come to a place in between
When a person does that there's they're said to have been?
Centered you're really centered in that place between the mind and the soul
all great
Mystics have found that place
You know they don't just reject the mind altogether
Because the minds experience is valuable if I didn't know about the minds experience
I would I would touch a hot pan on the stove and burn myself or put my hand in the socket and
get a shock or walk off the edge of a cliff so my
Experience my mind is it is a good friend, and I'm not saying we should reject our mind
But all the true mystics and masters have found a way to marry the mind of the soul
rather than to lived exclusively in the mind
to the exclusion of the soul if I would if I had one piece
Of advice for human beings it would be connect with your soul
Find a way to connect with your soul every day
Not once a week when you go to church or synagogue or temple, but if you even do that?
But every single day. How do you recommend people connect? Well there's a thousand ways to do that?
Meditation guided imagery visualization ecstatic dance the whirling dervishes do it all the time
You know reading good poetry the praying you know there's a thousand ways
But it starts just willingness
You must be willing you must say okay. God or life or whatever word you want to use that's comfortable to you
I'm here, and I'm willing I'm willing to be quiet for a moment each day
With my soul if you do that often enough and regularly enough
Ultimately you'll discover an opening something happens, and it's not just a flash
But it occurs on a regular basis rule number three see life for what it is
But I think what creates anger is the mind
Thinking that what is going on should not be going on
That's something else should be happening so the mind starts looking at what's happening is saying it shouldn't be like this
God darn it it shouldn't be like this. I'm getting pretty mad this shouldn't be like this don't argue with life
It's it is what it is and when we stop arguing with life and see it for what it is see
Here's what here's to tie it all together
Lilou when I was down the street for a year toward the end of that time not the beginning I
Went through a lot of anger like you're talking about and a lot of
frustration
And disappointment, but finally I got to a place where I realized I
See what this is all about I see what this is this whole experience that I'm having
Has been given to me by life as an opportunity for me to
Really get clear on
what's important, and who I am and why I'm really here on the earth, and I was so stubborn about it for me
I had to be hit over the head with a two-by-four
I had a really loose everything lose my family lose my house lose
my job lose my income I even all I almost lost my life what threw me on the street was I was in an automobile
Accident in which I had my neck broken now
You know most people with a broken neck godd lesson don't live you break your neck you die
And if you don't die at the very least you're paralyzed from here down for life
god bless those folks somehow or another I
Escaped both
They didn't die and I wasn't paralyzed, but I broke my neck
Sure as we're sitting here
but I just
In the right place, you know one is off and the doctors said you know it's you're so lucky
You're just amazingly lucky
That's your neck snapped in a place where it wasn't crucial and there aren't rape there are many places like that
in your neck
but you you you escaped now having escaped death having escaped life as a as a paraplegic and
Having found yourself on the street with nothing to your name one pair of shoes one pair of pants three shirts
Having gone through all that
What's really important rule number four my personal favorite fully express yourself
98% of the world's people are spending 98% of their time on things that don't matter
On things that have nothing to do with why we're here
If we get caught up in our doing this. Oh, you don't understand. I'm a camera man
That's what I do
I'm I'm an audio technician. That's what I do
No, you don't understand. I I do interviews. You know I write books. That's what I do
But those doing this functions are meaningless unless they are ways to demonstrate
what we're really here to accomplish
And what we're really here to accomplish is the fullest
expression of who we really are
People who step into that
Activity and
come from that awareness
Are people who change the lives of
everyone whose life they touch
rule number five wake up one of the biggest mistakes that people make is thinking that the
the things they're doing that they're required to do them
When in fact they're making a free choice to do that there are plenty of people who don't work
There are people who actually abandoned their families rather than work
There's so unhappy you know in their life that they just chuck it all and walk away from it
so
The problem with humanity is we keep on making a series of free choices, and then we call ourselves the victims of our own choices
So what I say to people of my audience is if you don't want to go to work and support your family
Then don't who's making you do that who told you how to do that. Oh, I just can't walk away
Why not people do it all the time?
I'm not saying it's the right thing to do
I'm saying, but when you do what you claim to be the right thing of your own free choice
And then you claim you yourself to be the victim of doing the right thing
Then your disowning your own self
Your disowning your own choices for heaven's sake if you're gonna do what you think is right at least be proud of it
Don't don't look don't let yourself. Talk yourself into that you're the victim of it
What does that say about you if you're the victim of it? What does that say about you? You know? Well? I'm only I'm only
Supporting my family and paying my bills and doing what's right because I have no choice
What's that say about you? No, no of course you have choice
There's no such thing as no choice
So I say to people let's understand that what this statement means there's nothing you have to do
There's nothing we have to do is God's Way of telling us it's another it's another way of saying you have free choice always
About everything but for goodness sakes stop making free choices and call yourself the victim of them wake up
Notice, what's happening
Every act is an act of self definition
Everything we do defines who we are
But we shouldn't you know?
Do all these wonderful things that define who we are and then
Fail to lay claim to them reject them call them not our own rule number six know who you really are
Because a lot of people walk with masks and try to please others
Well, they do when living authentically seems like a really important thing
Of course it is if people are trying to please others
It's because they do not know who they really are
When you know who you really are and have chosen to step into the living of that
the idea of pleasing someone else
becomes less and less
Useful to you less and less attractive
less and less beneficial
because too often in order to please someone else you have to abandon who you really are and
betrayal of yourself
In order not to betray another mm-hm is betrayal nonetheless mm-hm
It's the highest betrayal mm-hm, so we learned that as we get older and we learned that oh. I'm not going to betray myself
Anymore rule number seven transform fear the biggest problem on the planet today is fear
it's been a problem for a long time, but it's a
Huge problem now. It's getting bigger every day and the reason that fear is problem of course is that it affects everything
Everything we think and say and do all the decisions and choices we make
All of our reactions all of our responses
Everything that we're experiencing can come from only one of two places conversations with God has made that very clear to me
We're either coming from love
Where we're coming from fear and my observation is that most people most of the time and myself more than I would like to acknowledge
coming from fear
So we have to look at our fears and find out what is fear. Anyway. What is it all about?
What are we afraid of and?
What impact is it have and the choices and decisions and the creations
For which we have made ourselves
Responsible by the way, that's one of the first fears that there is the fear of being responsible the fear of
placing yourself in a position of
Responsibility for all that we are creating
So fear is the first aspect of the human experience as I understand it that?
We need to work very hard
To heal and I might even say to transform you transform fear
And you transform the world rule number eight focus on the right things
You can't get to the top of Mount Everest if you're deep-sea diving
So you so if you try to do one thing but doing another
Obviously you can't accomplish it so the reason that we can't accomplish
What we say we want is that we what we say we want is the wrong thing. We're after the wrong thing if we were
Truly understood the real reason and purpose of life
we would be wanting and
Yearning for and seeking to achieve what we came here to achieve
While we came to the planet to begin with it is what what human life is all about
And what we don't understand is if we did that if we just retrained our focus to what it is
We really were designed to achieve
All the rest would fall in on us without effort all the things we think we want peace health safety security
Opportunity love joy all the rest would
Automatically show up in our lives without without any effort on our part rule number nine
Go with the flow if you're in the middle of
difficulties and problems
How can you feel gratitude and the answer is you've got to fight to find the gift?
even in the difficult
That's what I was talking about earlier when you shift your perspective
From the perspective of the mind because I want to tell you something life will never make sense to your mind
If you're trying to get life to make sense with your mind
You might as well forget it because life will never make sense to your mind because mind is very logical and life is not
So so in order for life to make sense you've got to be I mean, it's literally out of your mind
and you've got to be into your soul and
When you begin to see life from the perspective of your soul
Then even in the midst as I was saying earlier even in the midst of the worst of it
You can see the gift and what you can see the gift, then you can say. Thank you God
So thank you God for this gift
Which I would not have been able to perceive had I not embraced the perspective of the soul
but now I see well even this horrible situation is bringing to me I
even see that
but again I want to say so this is important because
When you see that when you see the gift and begin to move into gratitude the very shift the shift away from
Resisting to gratitude changes the exterior energies such that the situation itself improves
Sometimes automatically without you doing anything I have a favorite thing that I like to say life will resolve itself in the process of life
itself
if you simply appreciate
life itself
So what I've learned to do is to just go with
The fall I hate this track beyond belief, but it's true mm-hmm just
Let the river go by
Stop, try to make the river
Go where you think the river is supposed to go and rule number ten the last time before a very special bonus clip is be
Divine fish something quite extraordinary going on here
Most of us don't even know what it is
we don't know what it's
We don't even know it's happening
But it is happening
Every moment of every minute of every hour of every day. It's happening. It's life
happening all around us and
Here's what not very many people really fully and deeply understand
much less appreciate
It's happening for a reason
There's a purpose behind it
There's a mechanism in place
There's a process that's being undertaken
in life by in life itself and that process is the process by which we
As the livers of this life as those who are living into the experience?
Create the experience we are living into as a means of experiencing and expressing
Who we really are
That life exists in all of its forms the beauty of the night sky
the wonder of a garden of flowers
the incredible expression of humanity itself
the feeling of love and the glory of a great idea
which has just come to someone and exploding within them and
awareness of something that they can't even name, but they can feel ah
They say that's me
Even as they see the night sky, they see a part of themselves there, there's a way to relate
Even as they see the flowers in a beautiful garden
They can see themselves there. There's something of beauty in me too and to look at this
I'm merely looking at myself in
another form
And even as we look at other people
We can relate and we say
There I go being a human being
wonderful being glorious
Being divine there's something quite extraordinary going on here. It's a process
Not only by which we experience ourselves as divine
But by which we define what divinity is to us
Can you imagine a process like this?
We're actually creating God
Through the process of being God as we are choosing to create it
That's what's happening
That's what's going on
That's the miracle of life itself flowing through you in you as is you?
And once you understand what's going on the purpose of all of it the divine
process
You take part in it in a brand-new way
Not unconsciously, but consciously not unintentionally, but intentionally
Not accidentally, but on purpose and you see every golden moment of know
as an opportunity to recreate yourself anew
In the next grandest version of the greatest vision you ever evolved about who you are
And if you do that only for a short time
For an hour a day an hour a week an hour a month
Your whole life will suddenly make sense to you
And you will touch the world
In a way that brings
Sense to the world
that's a life itself changes and
becomes the miracle it was intended to be
and human
decide to be
the miracle healer intended to be
So beaut
Being divided
I've got a very special bonus clip from Neal on how to ask yourself the four fundamental questions of life
But before that I want to know what did you learn from this video?
What was the single biggest lesson that you were going to apply somehow to your life or your business?
Leave it down in the comments below when you write it down as much more likely to actually
Happen for you, so put it down in the comments. Thank you guys so much for watching
I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is much love see you soon, and enjoy the bonus clip
So people go through their entire lives without ever asking these
extremely powerful and fundamental questions
Number one Who am I?
number two
Where am I that is what is this place? That's called physicality what am I where am I what is this?
Number three why am I where I am?
Why am I here and?
number four
What is it my opportunity to do about that? What do I intend to do about that?
now I'll give you bite my answers and
By the way one when I say where am I don't mean where am I right now in the supermarket?
or at the train station
Or I don't mean that I mean where am I in the broadest?
Sense that is what is this place this earth this environment in the cosmos you know where am I so?
How I would answer those questions if I was looking into the mirror right now
Neil
Who am I I?
Am an individual of divinity I
make an expression of God I am a singular ization of
The singularity I am a derivation of the essential essence I am
to God as a wave is
to the ocean
Now I know when I say that sometimes
It sounds formulaic that is it sounds like an answer, and I've given a thousand times before it sounds like a formula answer
But I'm sorry if it sounds like an answer that I've given a thousand times before
Because I have given it a thousand times before I asked myself this question all the time
So, but when you internalize the answer what it's not just saying something by rote
but saying something in a way that has emotional content and meaning for you I
really am
a demonstration of divinity I really am an
Individual of all that is an individual of God
That sets a context it creates
the contextual experience of
My identity my true self then I go to the second question. Okay, if that's who I am then where am I?
What is this place that I find myself in the answer for me is I am in the realm of the relative
where things are
Relative to other things where there's big and small fast and slow up and down left and right
Here and there before and after now and then good and evil male and female
So I am in the realm of the physical
where I have physicalized because Who I am is not physical its metaphysical the singular ization of
Singularity that I am is a soul or a spirit if you please
But that spirit has chosen to physicalize in the realm of physicality so that I might express an experience
myself that's the third question why am I where I am I am in the realm of the physical because
That is the only aspect of the kingdom of God. It's all the kingdom of heaven
It's the only aspect of life
The only place within the life's spheres within the realms of life where I can really experience and express
My true nature. I can't do it in the realm of the absolute because in the realm of the absolute I
Simply know who I am I always am divine. It's always here. It's always now
I am always the experience and the expression of love
So I am always loved here, and now love here and now love here
And now that's all very lovely to know that but I want to experience it
I want to express it so the
Expression of it is what occurs when I'm in the realm of the physical and that's why I'm in the realm of the physical
That's why I'm living my life the way. I'm living it because it's giving me a chance to express my true nature and
The fourth question, what is it your opportunity to do about that?
that
Question is answered in every single moment
In every golden moment of now from one moment to the next each moment will provide a stage upon, which you can
Act out I want a sense not in the sense of pretending, but in the sense of simply putting into action
to act out your
Decision and your choice about who you are
For instance right now because you asked me this question
This golden moment gives me a chance to act out my idea of who I am and my idea of Who I am is that
Aspect of divinity called clarity I am clear about Who I am
Why I'm here and what my opportunity is and I'm demonstrating my clarity right now
That's how the whole formula works so the first question
And you say you want to ask this to yourself once or twice a quite price a day first question is Who am I?
Second question is where am I the third question is why am I here and?
The fourth question is what am I going to do about it?
Beautiful, that's it. It's a very simple formula, but it's very empowering
Because you can ask yourself the question anytime driving in the car standing in the shower movies for the post office
it doesn't matter you can ask yourself these questions, and it becomes a mental discipline to just check in and
Make sure that you're on track and it gotten haven't gotten lost in the labyrinth of life
Where it starts to seem like you're not who you are
And it starts to seem like you have no idea what's going on or why it's happening
More than one person has spent a minute or two asking themselves well. Why is this going on why I don't understand
Why is this happening to me?
But if you stay connected to the four fundamental questions of life those questions go away raise your standard
Apple at the core is core values
Is that we believe that people with passion?
Can change the way people?
Now one drop of my self-worth depends on your it's supposed to mean. I don't ever give up I'd have to be
Dead or absolutely incapacitated. Hey believe nation if you want to see my all-time
Favorite top 10 most a success. I have a very special secret video for you
These are the individual clips that I have personally learned the most from and applied to my life
And my business check the link the description for details